you know i feel like
south south florida in general
has really had a it's
it's moment is still happening but it
kind of really kicked off like where
nationally like some of the bigger
artists
were all from you know obviously kodak
black is one of those guys uh x um
little pump you know we can go on and on
and on but i do feel like you
and uh
the raider clan really kicked off that
entire
just that whole entire wave at us
out of south florida i mean of course
and i'm a good respect whereas dude you
know like space goes perp really was
like the driving force for that [ __ ] at
the time when he first came out and him
and rocky was running together until the
beef happened but when it came down to
raider clan and the whole aesthetic and
everything before we disbanded like we
was really trying to bombard the
industry on some [ __ ]
like when we were young and we was all
in high school at the time like y'all
laid the roots for all this other [ __ ]
that's going on you know what i'm saying
for sure of course all that [ __ ] came
from us yeah a hundred percent and and
uh yeah you definitely you need to get
you get your flowers fat yeah it's crazy
because when you think about that we
were just talking about it yesterday
that asap rocky's uh space goes perp
thing
um such an unfortunate thing because
it's like what what if that never would
have happened like you know what i'm
saying like man listen if that would
have never happened you know we probably
would have had a stronghold on the game
right now you know what i'm saying
because we was like the driving force of
the culture of both raider clan and asap
mm-hmm
yeah and a lot of the aesthetic and a
lot of the vibe i feel like that rocky
had for the asap mob
you know
was heavily influenced by the raider
clan [ __ ] as well yeah i mean
when it came down to everything that was
going on and then you know when perpin
rocket was going through it and [ __ ] and
you know
black land radio 66.6 didn't come out
before i heard live love asap or pesos
you know what i'm saying yeah so
i still have respect for rocky i still
respect rocky to this day you know what
i'm saying but i give credit where on
creditors do if it wasn't for perp and
it wasn't for raider clan i wouldn't
have a platform to be denzel curry you
feel what i'm saying right so i'ma
always give respect to them regardless
of what the [ __ ] me and this [ __ ] go
through right you know what i mean
what's your relationship like what is
perp up to do do you have a relationship
with him anymore
i don't know i don't talk to food like
that he don't talk to me i don't talk to
him but we still you know
he'll big me up and then he'll
disrespect me in the same place
in the same week
you know but it's all love from my point
right i hope it's all love from him and
it is what it is